hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to time or
inferno now this is a that's a pleasant
opening screen
to a game that i have played before or
at least
i played the prior incarnations of this
game whoa
hello nice effects uh-huh
at least they improved the door sounds
but if it's anything like the other
timer games i expect a lot of very
very high quality jump scarage oh
look what am i looking at why am i
looking
what am i looking for oh no
they shouldn't have come here you
shouldn't have either
hi you are just uh
full of beans oof okay excuse pardon me
oh
hi hello okay
i don't know if i should be looking at
that guy ugh
is he looking at me no he's not looking
at me
okay
[Music]
he's almost adorable oh look at you
oh you're just a bag of dicks
why is it looking at you why is what
looking at me
[ __ ] off [ __ ] you what are you doing
what are you doing
oh is this just gonna be my buddy now
well i'm gonna call you
oliver the eye
[Music]
wait what let's go oliver
we have an adventure to take care of
oliver oh no i lost oliver
oh oliver oh no oh no
oh hey oh no what are you
oliver
[Music]
why are you back
so
okay i'm the monster here
[Music]
you